hey I'm Greg Alva and I'm John Humphrey
we're going to do a video that is a
little bit different today actually a
lot different we've never done something
like this but it should be a fun
experiment should be interesting
hopefully you guys find it intriguing we
have a topper war tier at our patreon
page this one comes today from a man
named Michael B Omnimedia whose channel
is blowing up by the way he told me they
is finally gonna get his first youtube
check major accomplishment bloody very
cool very cool
I'm talking about go check out his
channel is seriously a wonderful
youtuber so he basically said to us I
saw The Grudge 20/20 in your words as
with Halloween 2018 why do you think
studios are giving these movies the same
names as the original films despite
being sequels to those films he was
asking for like a podcast and I haven't
told them we're not doing the podcast
we're gonna do an entirely different it
sort of became a springboard a whole
wide variety of thoughts of like I
wonder this and I wonder that to answer
your question Michael B it's just
marketing that's all it is it's a brand
name recognition so many sequels or
software reboots now as opposed to just
a part two you know that and I think it
increases your chances of accidentally
putting the new one on the similar way
that like streaming music when I entreat
you industry I wonder if maybe there was
a certain element of trying to trick
people into that view that's a
conspiracy so I thought it'd be fun to
do a comparison game I wanted to look at
the reception of each of these films and
see which one's did better and or worse
with critics and audiences since they
both have the same title but their
sequels I just felt it'd be a fun
comparison game what we're gonna do
instead of using just our own personal
opinion and doing some ranking system
based off of that we're gonna use the
number system behind Rotten Tomatoes
since that's where most people go we're
gonna use the critics percentage score
the audience score but more importantly
we're gonna use the average rating from
both that makes a bit difference and it
is a different type of variable here
specific user ratings it sounds like
it's gonna be a little bit confusing
it'll be clearer as we go so to make
things clear in this comparison game we
are only counting movies where it's easy
to get confused
movies like Halloween 1978 and Halloween
2018 they're not called that with the
year and they're they're just called
Halloween so that they can be easy to
get confused as to like is this the
sequel is it Surrey but what is it and
we'll also be using movies that are
pretty much the same title but they took
out words like the like fast and furious
and The Fast and the Furious or when
they just add like an S to it like alien
and aliens or predator and predators so
with that in mind we're gonna be
excluding movies like Rocky and Rocky
Balboa as I feel like you can
distinguish those two pretty well movies
like The Blair Witch Project and Blair
Witch even though they share a lot of
the same words I feel like you can
distinguish those pretty easily and
please do keep in mind a lot of these
are software reboots that are
technically a continuation so they
technically do qualify as sequels and
also to make disk really clear
we're going by the overall score of each
of these categories
none of these films have the same amount
of people reviewing them so we just
wanted to get that out of the way we're
going by the scores so we have 13
franchises here this is gonna be fun
most of these are just two movies each
but hey let's get into this the first
one since Michael B brought it up is
2004 is The Grudge vs. 2020s The Grudge
the 2004 is the garage has a critic
score of 39% in an audience score of 46%
with an average critic user rating 5
point 11 out of 10
audience score 3.0 7 out of 5 stars then
when you compare that to 2020s The
Grudge its a critic score of 19 percent
and an audience score of 23% the average
user rating of that of the critics being
4.0 5 out of 10 with an average rating
of audiences at 2 points 17 out of 5
stars
so this results in a 20% decline in
critics and a 23% decline from audiences
with the critics user rating decreasing
by one point oh six and an audience user
rating decreasing by 0.9 so in
conclusion 2020s The Grudge is generally
considered worse than a movie that was
already not well received which is a
bummer because the people I know who've
seen it said it was actually kind of
nifty and just overly reliant on jump
scares but you can't win them all and
win them all number two
that we have here is 1979 Star Trek
versus 2009 Star Trek now the Astra -
this one is 1979 Star Trek has the
subtitle of the motion picture but we're
gonna count it because let's face it
they only put the motion picture there
because there was a show on around that
same time so in order to differentiate
it they had to add the motion picture
there but most people's was called Star
Trek 1979 Star Trek versus 2009 Star
Trek and this one it gets really fun
1979 Star Trek has a critic score of 42%
and an audience score of 42% so they're
tied right there in the percentage score
and the average critic user rating is
five point seven two out of ten average
audience rating 3.0 9 out of 5 stars and
when you compare that to the 2009 soft
reboot but because of Spock and when
they do the timeline it is a
continuation the critic score is 94% and
the audience score is 91% with an
average critic user rating of 8 point 13
out of 10 and an average audience rating
4.2 7 out of 5 which means and I find
this really funny 2009 Star Trek did
better by 52% with critics 49% better
with audiences average rating from
critics it did better by two point four
one averaging from audiences one point
eighteen it's pretty crazy because 2009
Star Trek this soft reboot is generally
considered better by a much wider margin
you can't say the same thing for it into
darkness and Wrath of Khan does do it
did a better job well and yeah it also
was the first you know a reintroduction
in a long time and even though that
movie I feel like does hold something of
a contentious place it does seem to be
the most agreeable alright John give us
one all right well I first started off
by looking at alien and aliens alien
1979 has a critic score of 97% with the
audience down at 94% in the average
critic user rating was a whopping nine
point zero seven out of ten with the
audience rating being four point four
out of five stars so both basically
neck-and-neck pretty much up at the top
and then aliens comparatively rose with
the critic score to 99% and then the
audience stayed around 94 average critic
user rating was nine point zero one out
of ten which funny enough is slightly
lower than the previous films
and the average audience rating was four
point four five stars out of five stars
so all this means that you know got that
extra 2% from the critics while the
audience just liked it steadily as much
at least as far as the percentages go
and then the average critic rating
dropped point zero six percent and then
the audience row is point zero five
percent so slightly vary it's pretty
much the same then yeah yeah yeah this
one was of all the ones I looked at this
was the most consistent and the approval
remained high across the board in any
place where one dropped or one increased
it kind of seemed to balance itself out
you know so yeah alien and aliens is a
good one-two punch now let's look at
nineteen seventy it's Halloween versus
2018 s Halloween so 1970s eighths
Halloween a classic in the horror films
and I think just regarded as a you know
classic film critics score a whopping 96
percent an audience score of 89 percent
average critic or user rating at eight
point six nine average audience rating
at 4.33 compare it to 2008 teens
Halloween critics score at 79 percent
audience score at 70 percent average
critic user rating six point seven eight
average audience rating three point six
eight out of five stars which means 2018
s Halloween did worse with critics by
seventeen percent did worse with
audiences by nineteen percent all things
considered for an official part two
after so many years or the whole lot of
movies in between yeah that's pretty
good that's pretty damn good because
average ratings from critics only did
worse by one point nine one average user
rating from audiences only did worse by
0.65 even though 2018 s Halloween was
not as well received it's still did good
amongst audiences and critics all things
considered as far as the drops go and
this for however many years passed
between them it's pretty decent I would
say and especially with the status that
Halloween holds being a potential
kneecap for people who are purists yeah
because that's something I feel like you
have to factor in with a lot of these
soft reboots and speaking of soft
reboots let's look at the Evil Dead 81
and Evil Dead 2013 I do want to
establish that we did do like some
research on this to make sure we were
right because every like report of
it's said that it does ultimately serve
as a soft reboot it's still technically
a continuation like that's how these how
the filmmakers were approaching it yeah
and I feel like there are little nuggets
like Ash's car and the fact that there
is an easter egg bruce campbell you know
cameo so yeah they seem to be at least
touching the same world and we know that
Evil Dead exists with University happing
and all that sort of stuff so yeah soft
reboot sequel thing so the original film
the Evil Dead has a critic score of 95
percent with an audience score of 84 so
you know the audience aren't as hot on
it average critic user ratings eight
point zero four out of ten average
audience is four point zero nine out of
five pretty similar you know when you
think about it Evil Dead 2013 then has a
critic score of 62 audience is a little
higher on it sixty-three percent and
then the average critic rating was six
point one six out of ten average
audience rating was three point five
four so we see some drop I mean you know
it definitely Evil Dead is another one
of those classics this was a markedly
different approach so we saw 33% of a
drop from critics between the OG and the
reboot while the audience score only
dropped 21% so you know again the
audiences are slightly higher than the
critics throughout this one average
critic rating fell one point eighty
eight points and the average audience
score ratings fell point zero five five
zero point five five sorry yeah so if
and only fellow that much it's actually
from terms of an audience perspective
it's pretty good yeah it's pretty that's
why the user ratings are important to
factor in here yeah and the reboot also
have had more than three times the
amount of critics reviewing it and I did
a vague amount of math on that and even
though there is a higher over our you
know more there is a higher percentage
of negative middling responses than
there was to the original film crunch
that number and less than half the
amount of the users reviewed the reboot
as reviewed the original which I thought
was interesting so yeah that's that's
something to is you you get a whole
different amount of people each time all
right so let's look at two thousands
final destination versus 2009's
the final destination so to thousands
final destination which is a film I
actually quite liked when I was ten
years old at a critic score of 34
percent hey man start off strong look
but looky here but the audience score is
68% and average critic user rating for
point set
two out of ten average audience rating
3.66 comparatively 2009's
the final destination which was not in
fact the final destination got a critic
score of 29% and an audience score of 35
percent so the average critic user
rating is four point two three average
audience rating two point eight one
which means 2009 film did worse
marginally with critics by only five
percent but with audiences thirty three
percent average critic user rating
diverse by zero point four nine average
audience ratings at worst by 0.85 all
things considered though even though
2009 s final destination numbers saw a
decline generally the similar any
numbers even though they're like there's
a lot of installments in between
generally similar it seems like the
critics aren't so much about it an
audience's think alright moving on to
the Fast and the Furious was the next
one I did the Fast and the Furious 2001
and then Fast and Furious in 2009 drop
in those does the critic score for the
original film was fifty three percent in
the audience score was much higher at
seventy four and then the average critic
user rating was five point three seven
out of ten three point eight five out of
five from the audience it's a great
audience for ya that's I mean what do
you think about it yeah you you see that
three and you're like oh it's it's
alright but it's it's very close to four
yeah then you look at Fast and Furious
oh nine you have a 29% critic score 67%
audience score again the audience is
much more enthusiastically critic rating
is four point five seven out of ten
audience rating generally is three point
seven one out of five little bit of drop
critical you had a twenty four percent
drop from oh one two oh nine audience
score only drops about seven percent
which is decent and then the average
critic rating dropped zero point eight
points out of ten and audience dropped
more but still small one point one four
out of five stars it's a crowd-pleaser
the critics have never been really high
on this drop is very much more drastic
among the critics than the audience all
right so here we go we got two thousand
two is the ring versus twenty seventeen
s rings so two thousand two is the ring
and I was actually surprised to learn
about the audience score in this one the
critic score was seventy one percent
which is really good for a horror film
especially at that time yeah um and the
audience score I was surprised by how
low
48% not even certified fresh' average
critic user rating 6.6 one out of 10
audience two point nine seven out of
five stars and he compare that with
rings it was a box office ball he myth
2017 rings had a critic score of eight
percent at an audience score of twenty
three percent so average critic user
rating out of 10 was 3.19 average
audience rating out of five stars two
point three five two thousand seventeen
rings did worse with a sixty three
percent decline from critics twenty five
percent decline from audiences user
rating did worse from critics by three
point four to user rating diverse from
audiences by zero point six two so
that's a pretty big drop especially in
the terms of critics when you factor in
the average audience score no not so
much but immensely inferior in terms of
the critical department yeah well one
thing I've noticed too is that when you
look at the critic rating and the user
rating often if you double the user
rating you you essentially get the out
of ten score and so it's interesting to
see how neck-and-neck those numbers can
be and when one is significantly higher
than the other like in that last example
the critics drop significantly more than
the audience I do find that interesting
well there's always more audience
members than critics to you know I think
it's actually you know a lot of ways a
little bit more of a reliable number
let's move on to a monster movie now we
got Godzilla or Gojira the original 1954
film and then the beloved 1985 sequel of
the same name yeah so keep in mind cuz
some people might be like it's easy to
look at this and go roland emmerich or
the Godzilla won by Gareth Evans uh
words Edwards my bad the second I said
it I was like I think I'm wrong needs to
make it though like a like a raid style
this Godzilla 85 is an act is actually a
sequel whereas those other ones are
straight-up American remake suits so the
first original film has a critic score
of 93 percent audience score tad bit
lower at 89 and then the average user
rating for critics was seven point six
seven out of ten pretty high average
audience rating was even higher four
point two nine out of five see that's
time about those audience ratings and
audience scores like when you see the
audience go for eighty nine percent like
Oh below 90 but four point two nine
out of five sounds higher than 89% yeah
to see how the the percentage scores and
the average ratings differ because
sometimes you look at them and you're
like well by the average rating this is
actually rating lower or higher or
whatever but moving on to the 85 sequel
we got a critic score of 20% audience is
up at 66 3 x plus better average Creek
user rating was 2.8 one out of 10
glowing average rating from the audience
was three point six six out of five this
one saw a very sharp drop from critics
their score plummeted from 73 plummeted
73% and audiences only dropped 23 so
again you you're looking at like a three
times difference the average critic
ratings dropped four point eight six
points out of a possible 10 only 0.6
three drop out of five for the audience
so even if you double that it's still
less of a drop in the critics by a wide
whole-number margin so it's safe to say
most everybody prefers the original film
the audiences were a bit kinder and a
bit more open to the newer you know 85
sequel seems to have kind of a mess a
decent response act and of all the films
that I looked at this one was the
harshest drop amongst critics so what I
did was like I came up with this idea
for the video and I gathered all the
images of the ratings but I didn't
actually do the comparison numbers but
John did this one for the Muppet movie
I'm gonna read this for the first time
to see what the actual rating is on this
as though you got the Muppet movie 1979
then you got the Muppets 2011 and I kind
of feel like it's a similar situation
like what we said with Star Trek the
movie and star so the critic score on
the Muppet movie is 79 was 88% audience
score 88% well that is exactly the same
average critic user rating 8.0 two out
of ten average audience rating for point
19 out of five you compare that to the
2011 The Muppets whoa it has a higher
critic score huh does okay we're
audience score wow it's a 95 percent
critics score 80% audience score so
critics score actually Rises seven
percent here while the audience score
drops by 8 percent fascinating I didn't
see that coming yeah there are a lot of
I was just gathering all the images I
wasn't really paying attention to the
so the average crew degrading drop is
point 0.09 points at a possible 10
average audience rating drops 0.2 star
points out of 5 so that's a harsher drop
for audiences there okay
but yeah both are pretty well liked with
the 2011 films receiving basically just
a smidge more critical love though the
the percentages drop and both user
ratings due to UM the audiences are
still technically a little higher in the
user ratings departments I found that
interesting John take this one man this
is your movie yeah the thing so we got
John Carpenter's original 1982 film and
then we have the reboot prequel from
2011 of the same name
critics score for John Carpenter 82 is
84% audience scores 92 percent average
critic user rating seven point three
nine and a 10 four point three three out
of five from the audience
comparatively we got 35% from the
critics for the reboot prequel 42% from
the audience not good yeah we got a five
point oh two out of ten almost right in
the middle from the critics on user
ratings and three point oh eight out of
five from the audience a lot of drivers
but this was almost both of them I mean
critics dropped 49% audiences dropped
the full 50 percent which is a pretty
significant drop for this ratings from
critics dropped two point three seven
points out of ten one point two five
star points out of five from the
audience which would be technically
again a higher fall than the critical if
you double it the conclusion I drew here
yeah was that the twenty like the thing
I found funny about this was that the
2011 film has less fresh reviews than
the entire number of reviews there were
like there are only 60 odd something
reviews for that film and out of however
many the new one got not even that many
were positive so this had the the
sharpest audience drop of all the movies
I looked at and everyone seems to prefer
to carpenter Smithee
alright now here's where it gets a
little bit tricky for so the number
reveal system will be a little bit
different here because these next two
movies are three movies each so this one
is 1971 shaft versus 2000's shaft versus
2019 shaft which Coleman hates all
shafts
called it shafts they might as well
alright but this one's actually really
interesting to me um you'll see by the
moment when we get to twenty nineteen
nineteen seventy one shaft has a critic
score of eighty eight percent an
audience score of 68 percent so the
average critic user rating seven point
four seven average audience rating three
point six four two thousands shaft with
Christian Bale the villain critic score
67 percent audience score forty one
percent it's pretty low average critic
user rating 6.09 average audience rating
three point oh seven here's where this
gets really interesting
2019 shaft has a critic score of thirty
one percent that's the lowest of them
all but it's audience score is the
highest of them all a ninety four
percent so talk about a divisive movie
critic user rating four point five eight
average audience rating four point five
eight Wow and one of those is out of ten
and the other is out of so the stacked
list goes like this a flashed on screen
here is shaft from the critics you'll
see for it goes from eighty eight
percent down to thirty one and then from
audiences there's a month there's a
pretty big gap there so from shaft 1971
to shaft twenty nineteen twenty two
percent higher on the audience score
rating average critic user rating you
can see right here average audience user
rating shaft 2019 beats them all so
strangely in the in the scoring of these
films 2019 shaft undoubtedly scored the
highest amongst the audiences so take
from that what you will and then the
last one we have here 1987's predator
versus 2010's predators versus 2018 the
predator if you just looked at most of
the posters over the 1987's predator
will all look like they're the same
movie some different posters John what's
1987's predator 1987's predator sits at
81 percent from the critics and a eighty
seven from the audience average critic
user rating is seven point one out of
ten average audiences four point one
three out of five and then the 2010's
predators I like it which we both like
critics score 65 percent says fresh
audience score fifty two percent and
that one actually pretty surprised to
see that the critic score is higher than
the audience go on that
and Ryan's definitely see more like a
crowd will love it but critics would
average critic user rating 5.83 average
audience rating 3.27
here's the fun one 2018 - the predator
critics score third 800 percent average
on the audience score 34% average critic
user rating four point eight eight out
of ten average artist rating two point
six one lower so here it is from the
critics you'll see a big decline from
1987 predator to the predator steadily
and then audience is pretty but pretty
similar number and decline when you look
at from the audience score area because
the critics was 81% and 32% 1987's
predator the first one 87% the predator
34% average critic user rating you could
see the drop here average audience user
ratings big drop so my opinion
considering the amount of decline this
franchise has experienced maybe it is
time to just let the franchise die even
though I think predators is rather
underrated and deserves a little more
praise or perhaps a second viewing but
in terms of scoring from doing this
comparison list of the sequels or soft
furry boots that share the same title
there's only one movie here that
definitely did better in terms of
scoring overall reception from audiences
and critics and that is Star Trek that's
the only one aliens we almost put here
but there's o'the good there pretty much
equal there's like a point percentage
difference but literally out of all
these movies that share the same title
for the most part Star Trek is the only
one yeah that's a soaring increase in
approval yeah and it's funny I mean
because this is such a conversation that
we have even more nowadays about like
critics and audience is being detached
it's funny to watch the the you know the
ups and downs of it all because more
often than you would expect they're kind
of side by side it appears or even when
the percentage rating yet doesn't quite
match oftentimes the user ratings will
be a little less drastic or a little
closer together or something like that
yeah so there's not as much of a
difference unless you're a shaft fan
alright guys well what do you think of
this video what's - which one of these
compare
since surprised you the most is leave
your thoughts down below don't ask us to
crunch the numbers on remakes there are
too many a whole month comparing the
numbers and now this video is eight
hours know every every remake foreign
language films we can do like a
livestream for 48 straight hours just
going over all the numbers I have to
narrow it down like here the remakes
that did perform better yeah maybe maybe
a stable of 20 damn Earl has charting
with Dan for the box office numbers and
will we'll monitor Rotten Tomatoes and
audience approval ratings here all right
well thank you Michael B for asking me
this question which springboarded this
topic appreciate it buddy guys seriously
check out Michael B's Channel Omni media
doing a lot of reactions and a lot of
reviews ascend your favorite pop culture
things out there great geekdom stuff he
covers and he's a lot more knowledgeable
than us he will surpass us in viewers in
no time subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell get
notified whenever we got a new YouTube
video up if you like more of these
discussion type videos or strange
analysis videos I haven't seen anyone do
this kind of video so I was like here's
our opportunity to try something out but
if you like this kind of video you want
some more stuff kind of like this let us
know in the comment boxes much love
thank you guys